otro tipo de circuito con amplificadores
operacionales el llamado amplificador
fumador vamos a analizar cómo funciona
este lo que tenemos dibujado aquí es un
circuito amplificador inversor con una
sola entrada llamaremos a esta de a por
ahora y tenemos el voltaje de salida y
hablamos antes de cómo funcionaba este
donde el voltaje de salida era función
de bea por la proporción de estas dos
resistencias voy a dar un pequeño giro a
esto y analizaremos un diferente tipo de
circuito añadiré otra resistencia aquí
de esta manera y una segunda entrada la
llamaremos
así que tenemos a área aquí está será rv
y llamaremos a esta resistencia de
retroalimentación r efe
y nuevamente la pregunta es cuál es el
voltaje de salida en términos de las
entradas vea y bebe utilizaremos el
concepto de tierra virtual
de tierra
actual
el concepto de tierra virtual aplica a
la mayoría de los circuitos con
amplificadores operacionales y es una
manera muy útil para simplificar el
análisis y cuando utilizamos una tierra
virtual una de las cosas que me gusta
hacer es simplemente dibujar un pequeño
símbolo aquí
para mi tierra virtual la tierra virtual
como repaso si el voltaje que sale de
este amplificador operacional está en un
rango razonable un valor cercano a más o
menos 10 volts y ya que la ganancia de
este amplificador es enorme del orden de
100 mil o un millón eso significa que
cuando esto está funcionando
adecuadamente estos dos voltajes serán
muy cercanos el uno del otro a lo muchos
se separarán por micro volts y ya que
son tan parecidos podemos solo decir que
son iguales con fines de analizar este
circuito y ya que esta entrada a está a
cero volts está ésta
pulse eso significa que esta entrada se
acerca mucho a
pero bots así que este nodo de aquí
decimos que es una tierra virtual así
que continuemos analicemos este circuito
y lo que queremos encontrar es el
voltaje de salida en función de de a
p
veamos si podemos hacer eso analizando
mi circuito otra cosa que sé de los
amplificadores operacionales que es muy
importante es que la corriente que
circula en una entrada del amplificador
operacional es cero o prácticamente cero
y para los fines que tenemos aquí
podemos considerarla como cero bien así
que tenemos cero volts en ese nodo y no
tenemos corriente yendo en esta
dirección
así que busquemos esta corriente de aquí
para descubrir qué es la llamaremos y
y podemos expresar ahí en términos de b
a bb y estos dos valores de resistencia
podemos escribir y es igual a que sucede
que tenemos aquí tenemos a
aquí
y ya
y de fluyendo por aquí eso significa que
y es igual
y ah
más
es cierto y déjame escribir
ve
en términos de la ley de ohm así que
tendremos
es igual a a que equivale ya ya es este
voltaje dividido entre herrera y este
voltaje es vea menos cero volts
así que queda vea entre herrera y ahora
escribamos lo que equivale a y b y b
vemos este voltaje aquí este voltaje es
p b -0 simplemente de b
sobre r&b
ese es un paso hemos escrito esta
corriente en términos de lo que está
sucediendo en el lado de las entradas
por aquí ahora algo que sabemos ya que
esta corriente de cero y que sabemos
sabemos que esta corriente es y
y si circula por rf etiquetar hemos al
voltaje en rf de esta manera ahora
escribamos una expresión para y en
términos de rf y este voltaje de aquí
que es este voltaje de aquí bien veamos
los dos extremos este nodo de aquí es de
0 volts y en este lado es el voltaje de
salida así que la corriente ahí la
corriente en ese lado es 0 - el voltaje
de salida
/ / efe
esa es la ley de ohm para esta
resistencia de aquí
ahora sabemos que esta corriente es
igual a esta corriente así que pongamos
estas dos expresiones juntas lo haré por
aquí puedo escribir menos el voltaje de
salida sobre r
es igual a
ve a sobre área más bebé sobre r&b
ahora para obtener la función final solo
multiplicar por rf en ambos lados y nos
queda de sal igual a tomamos el signo
negativo de una vez menos
rf sobre
ah
de a
más
efe sobre heredé por
y esa es nuestra respuesta es el voltaje
de salida en función de vea y bebe las
dos entradas y ves que la proporción de
las resistencias las dos proporciones de
las resistencias están participando en
la respuesta y ayuda a hacer un caso
especial de esto hagamos que todas las
resistencias sean iguales
digamos que r es igual a rv que es igual
a rf y solo para elegir un número real
diremos que todas son iguales a 10
'kilos' oms ahora veamos a que equivale
esto ahora tenemos que el voltaje de
salida es igual a
aún tenemos el signo negativo así que
tenemos una especie de inversión aquí rf
sobre herrera es 1 y sólo nos queda ver
y rf entre r&b es 1 así que esto es bebe
esto es lo que nos da el nombre informal
para este circuito es conocido como
y si castor
a la gorra
digamos que quiero utilizar mi
amplificador fumador en una aplicación
en donde lo que quiero es que el voltaje
de salida equivalga digamos menos 2
+ 3
v
bien esto es lo que quiero obtener como
lo consigo
estos dos coeficientes son funciones de
los valores de las resistencias esta de
arriba es nuestra expresión original lo
que quiero es que rf sobre y rea sea
igual a 2 y que rf sobre r&b
sea igual a 3
así que puedo elegir valores es la misma
rf así que debo de ajustar los valores
de r&b aquí puedo escoger valores de
resistencias puedo decidir que el valor
de rf
12 kilos oms luego puedo decir que erré
a sea
kilo
y que rb
igual a
4 kilos oms
esto me dará las proporciones que quiero
e implementaremos esta función de aquí
así que llenar esos valores arriba
dijimos que rf
era igual
12 kilos
era era igual
kilo oms
rv sería igual a 4 kilos
y hemos diseñado un circuito que
implementa nuestra función sumadora este
es un circuito con amplificadores
operacionales bastante útil